a tangled mass of yarn and ribbon sounds
more like what you'd find in the back
room of a craft store or a forgotten
closet than a mysterious creature worthy
of investigation and yet that's exactly
what
scp-066 appeared to be or at least it
did at first glance but the scp
foundation doesn't contain and study
just anything and there was and still is
something incredibly strange just below
the surface of scp-066
also known as eric's toy at first eric's
toy seemed to be completely harmless and
even helpful a knot of string that
produced strange but harmless items and
effects but the foundation soon
discovered a dark side to scp-066
while it may be referred to as a toy
this is no mere play thing
scp-066 weighs only about one kilogram
and appears to be a braided bunch of
yarn and ribbon though there is no
apparent musical capability within the
strands of yarn and ribbon themselves
music can be produced by moving
individual strands one at a time when it
was first being studied this scp was
composed of multi-colored strings and
ribbons but it has since undergone a
transformation and now presents an
appearance somewhat different from its
initial description the strands of yarn
and ribbon can be used to play the notes
of a diatonic scale c d e f g a b though
the research has not been able to
determine just how
scp-066 produces music or any sound at
all
scp-066 was thought to be completely
benign at first and was classified as
safe but following an incident known as
incident 066-2
its classification was adjusted to a
sub-category of euclid euclid impetus
euclid is a classification given to scps
that are more difficult to contain than
those classified as safe impetus in
latin means attack and specifies that
scp-066
is not only euclid class but on the more
aggressive side while 066 is not always
aggressive towards humans the events of
incident 066-2 prove that it is highly
unpredictable and should not be provoked
like many scps it proved that
underestimating its capabilities can be
a dangerous mistake before the incident
scp-066 displayed only charming if
unusual behavior various researchers
spent their time playing random
assortment of notes using its strings
curious about what would happen and
determined to record anything this
unusual ball of string had to offer they
did not yet know that the creature was
capable of any hostility and went about
their work with a lighthearted carefree
spirit after playing an improvised six
note melody with the strands a
researcher was thrilled to find that
scp-066 was capable of shape-shifting
its appearance changed to resemble a
small calico kitten for 17 minutes the
kitten was incredibly friendly rubbing
its head against the researcher's glove
hand and purring loudly ironically
enough the kitten also spent time
playing with a piece of string after the
17 minutes were up the kitten
transformed back into
scp-066's original form a few days later
another researcher played a different
melody on the strands and was surprised
to find that when they stopped the music
continued on its own the sound of an
acoustic guitar kicked in accompanied by
vocals with no visible source for either
sound the scp then played a four-minute
song with lyrics warning against the use
of sharp objects without the supervision
of a parent especially scissors after
the song ended the scp was silent for
the rest of the day the following week a
research assistant used the strands of
scp-066 to play the opening notes of
happy birthday and a chocolate cupcake
with a lit birthday candle appeared from
within the braided strings
against the warning of his peers the
assistant ate the cupcake in response
the scp played the rest of happy
birthday and the assistant suffered no
adverse effects from the cupcake
all this fun was brought to a swift end
when one scientist suggested that a
portion of
scp-066's yarn body be cut off and
removed so that the specimen could be
tested
on april 18th 2008 the event that would
become known as incident 066-2 took
place
a young man known only as d-066-4437
or d was assigned to the task
naturally he was a member of the highly
disposable d-class personnel but dee was
grateful for the opportunity as most
experiments of a similar nature involved
quite a bit more obvious risk
it was a simple enough job take a pair
of scissors snip off some yarn and bring
it back to the lab for further study
it was hardly on the level of
supervising 173
or being 682's latest chew toy
he entered the containment room where
scp-066 was lying dormant and still and
approached it with scissors he grabbed a
small handful of string and started to
cut as soon as the scissors began to cut
through the fabric the scp rolled out of
his grasp it came to a stop one meter
away
where it started to make a high-pitched
squeaking sound resembling the cry of a
frightened rabbit unsure what to do and
unprepared for this scenario dee
approached the entity again he snagged
another fistful of yarn and cut only for
066 to curl into a ball and roll away
from him again even faster this time
once it was safely on the other side of
the room and away from the scissors it
stopped moving only this time it didn't
squeak
instead for the very first time since
its containment it spoke in a deep
uncannily human voice and asked
are you eric after recovering from his
initial shock at hearing a voice come
out of a massive string he responded no
i'm not this answer said something off
in scp-066
and its form began to shift and change
the string wriggled around on the floor
unbraiding and wrapping around itself
into a mound the colors previously a
rainbow of shades shifted until every
strand was a blood red much to dee's
horror the transformation was not yet
complete small bumps began to emerge
from the spaces between the strands of
yarn popping out all over the bright red
mass if that wasn't terrifying enough
suddenly altogether as one they blinked
open revealing themselves to be over a
dozen small eyes every single eye was
focused at d studying him staring him
down
scp-066 then began to produce loud
abrupt dissonant notes like someone
banging on the keys of a piano d had
seen enough he abandoned his task and
fled the containment room after this
failed attempt to extract a sample
scp-066's behavior and its treatment of
personnel who interacted with it began
to change dramatically before the
incident the scp was largely dormant
only becoming active if a melody was
played using its strands following the
incident and its change of form 066
began to move on its own long strands of
its yarn body would move like tentacles
writhing and wriggling around at high
speed it no longer needed human
interaction in order to produce sound or
to produce any other effects at the
sight of any human regardless of the
human's behavior the scp would begin to
react with sound and effect within six
seconds the first of these effects was
noted by a research assistant who
entered the scp's containment facility a
week after the incident with d
as she approached 066 to take notes
about its current state and its new
ability to move a bee appeared out of
nowhere it stung the assistant and flew
away before it could be captured weeks
later a team of 11 personnel were
monitoring the scp when it suddenly
burst into a rendition of beethoven's
second symphony it produced this music
at a volume of over 140 decibels
permanently deafening three of the
personnel and causing permanent hearing
damage in the other aid it was theorized
that the scp did this as an act of
retribution for its perceived
mistreatment these personnel refused to
work with scp-066 again when a new team
was assigned to monitor the entity
everything seemed to be going well at
first it was moving around flailing its
tentacles of yarn at nothing in
particular and staring at the personnel
with its many eyes but otherwise was on
its best behavior then suddenly every
light in the room went dark and there
was a complete loss of visibility the
lights were unable to be turned on for
five hours and any attempt at an
alternate light source such as a
flashlight was unsuccessful it was as if
the darkness in the room swallowed any
and all light right up it was similar to
the oppressive darkness within scp-087
or the unlimited black of
scp-3001's shadow dimension the
personnel in the room later reported
hearing the sound of loud labor
breathing just behind their shoulders
though when they searched for a source
of the sound they could find nothing
there had been no recent anomalies
reported or any additional hostile
behavior instead whenever it sees a new
human
scp-066 repeats the name eric again and
again in the same deep voice
who is eric no one at the facility knows
or if they do they have not reported it
to any official channels it is possible
that the scp was once owned by someone
named eric and perhaps given the
circumstances under which
scp-066 first said the name eric
attempted to cut the threads of the
entity while it was in his care
unfortunately there are no official
records of how
scp-066 was discovered or why it was
brought to the foundation in the first
place its origins remain murky and as
mysterious as everything else about it
all that is known is that whoever eric
is scp-016
is determined to find him once the scp's
class was changed from safe to euclid
its containment procedures had to be
adjusted
while it was previously kept in a simple
room it is now contained in a tungsten
carbide box at its site's high value
item storage facility once a month the
box is inspected for damage to its
interior due to the scp's tendency to
use its appendages to wear down the
walls of the box over time
if there is any damage
scp-066 is to be moved to a new box
using a robotic arm that performs this
transfer in less than three seconds the
foundation has attempted to place
recording devices in the box with the
entity in order to monitor its behavior
when there are no humans present but the
scp destroys every recording device
placed inside of its containment box and
any attempts to record its behavior when
it is not being observed by humans have
been unsuccessful whatever it's doing
when there is no one around it wants to
keep a secret
on the surface
scp-066 is one of the less frightening
finds contained within the walls of the
scp foundation it does not have claws or
teeth or the ability to cause mass
deaths but it has incredible
unpredictable capabilities and seems
very capable of holding a grudge there
is so much that is unknown about it from
its origins to its form to its ability
to manifest matter from nothing and
there is something deeply unsettling
about this scp's unpredictable behavior
and increased hostility towards being
observed we do not know what it is done
and we do not know what it will do next
all we can do is wonder as we ponder the
nature of
scp-066 it does nothing but sit staring
with unblinking eyes waiting for eric to
come back